sister is married and has kids is that  something you see in your future one day  yeah for sure way in the future way in  the future but one day I'll write one  hundred percent Sophia Richie says she  wants to settle down someday but it  seems like it won't be with justin  bieber at least for now a source  confirmed to ET on Monday the pair has  split after six weeks of dating  explaining quote nothing serious or  dramatic happened just fizzled out the  duo first started heating up in early  August after they posted several cute  pics together on Instagram i'm just  posting what i really like but not  everyone was a fan of the couple times  of social media backlash prompted Sofia  to disable comments on her Instagram  pics and Bieber deleted his account  altogether  oh come  now that we know Justin and Sofia aren't  keeping each other company the question  is did you dig them as a couple or do  you think they're better off apart let  us know your thoughts on Twitter at T  now  you